lots of democrat politicians are
weighing in to tell us what ruth bader
ginsburg
allegedly said on her deathbed what was
the late justice's alleged death wish
but we actually don't need
second-hand accounts of justice
ginsburg's death wish
because she actually told us herself
just a few
years ago take a listen i i
do think that cooler heads will prevail
i hope sooner rather than later
the president is elected for four years
not three years
so the power that he has in year three
continues into year four and maybe
some members of the senate will will
wake up and appreciate
that that's how it should be that's how
it should be the president's power
continues into his fourth year
he has the power the right nay the
responsibility
to appoint a justice to the supreme
court that's exactly what's going on
and the democrats are promising quote
total war
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday comes from
jaden van dyke he says that
trump should replace ginsburg with biden
and that would force the left and
democrats to cancel joe biden that's
true that would force them finally to
take
those sexual assault allegations against
him seriously if they could invent a
bunch of ridiculous
sexual assault allegations against milk
toast judge
brett kavanaugh surely they can against
sniffy joe biden
you know one thing in all of this very
tense time i know we're all
sort of just tense we're worried we're
anxious
you need a really soft dress shirt and
buttercloth has
the absolute softest dress shirt that's
ever been invented there's no hyperbole
there at all
i wore my buttercloth shirt just this
weekend i wore it just on sunday
there's nothing like it you think that
when you put on an oxford dress shirt
right
it's going to be stiff it's going to be
scratchy right that's true of every
other dress shirt
not butter cloth they developed this
unbelievably soft fabric
but it's not using some crazy weird
synthetic
blend of who knows what's touching your
body it's somehow
a special blend of 100 long fiber cotton
and a unique manufacturing process that
makes it super
duper soft and the one that i wore on
sunday because you know me i'm sicily
and i perspire a little bit
i i wore their shirt that has this
incredible cooling technology
uses mint fibers in there that actually
cools you down i put it down i get a
little chill up my spine it's so
nice uh this wonderful company was
featured on abc's hit show shark tank in
2018 and
uh the shark tank guys loved it so much
they invested a bunch of money
and you should invest some money in your
in your buttercloth shirts as well
buttercloth is offering our listeners
twenty percent off on your first
purchase
go to buttercloth.com slash w l e s
to receive twenty percent off your first
full price order
buttercloth dot com slash knowledge k w
l e s
feeling is believing trying is believing
you will thank me later buttercloth.com
knowles back to all the tense
horrible anxiety-inducing madness the
democrats are promising
total war if president trump
exercises his constitutional right and
duty
to fill that supreme court seat now what
do they mean by total war they're
already burning down the country
they're already committing eluding
rioting arson they're already attacking
churches
there are so what does total war look
like are they going to use a nuclear
bomb
or something no what they mean is that
this is according to axios
they are considering a
a massive power play if
and i suppose eventually when they get
control
of the senate or the white house
most egregiously you know most most
worrisome to us
they want to add new states to the
country so they've talked about adding
puerto rico as a state if puerto rico is
added to the country that will
fundamentally shift the balance of power
that will give democrats very likely a
permanent majority
um it will give democrats a huge
advantage in the presidential election
probably they'll just win the
presidential election from then on out
they also want to turn the district of
columbia washington dc
into a state this is uh not only
cynical is also very stupid
the district of columbia is a federal
district on purpose it was carved out of
maryland and virginia right so right
there is plopped right in
and the reason for that is that no state
should have the seat of power for the
federal government in it
so there's this federal district and no
state that has that power now they want
to create a state out of it why
because they know that they'll get some
more votes and they'll get
some democratic senators out of it all a
very bad
idea my only question is
why do we care what they're threatening
you know there were a couple of
the last two never trump republicans
probably in the entire world
came out yesterday and they said we need
a big deal we need to come to a
wonderful compromise
we will not fill the supreme court seat
now and in exchange democrats will be
nice to us in 10 years that was more or
less what they said
they said that we will not exercise
our political power and our
constitutional responsibility now by
filling the seat
and for the next 10 years the democrats
have to promise not to pack the court
you know or do kind of crazy things like
ad states you see the problem with that
the problem with that is we are giving
up something real
right now for some democrat promise
10 years down the line
there's no enforcement mechanism how are
we supposed to believe that we're going
to get that
this is the exact same thing that reagan
fell for in the 80s
with that big amnesty he says amnesty
give amnesty now and then
you'll get border protection later guess
what happened reagan gave them amnesty
and then they never got the border
protection so that's the total war
that's being threatened
i just don't even know why we care what
they're threatening
there's nothing we can do about it that
they've shown that they're serious
they're willing to burn down the entire
country
they've shown that their word is no good
if they're promising some concession
down the line for something that we're
giving them now
so what i mean it's this classic it's
this classic squishy republican
thing which is gosh fellas we can't
exercise our power right now
which is legitimate because down the
line
democrats might hypothetically exert
some power that we won't like which
secretly they're already exerting
that's not an argument you gotta you
gotta play the hand that you were dealt
the hand we were dealt is this vacant
seat and we should fill that seat
and all of these threats that we're
getting from the democrats by the way
are they're trying to position them as
though they're the final wonderful wish
of ruth bader ginsburg
there's no evidence of that i do not
believe for one second that ruth
ginsburg in her dying breath said
please don't ever let a republican
president fill my seat i actually have
more respect for her than that
i i just don't think she did it i think
that's bs concocted by
exploitative democratic politicians how
about court packing that's the other
threat they're making
they're going to add new states they're
going to add new justices to the supreme
court and that way the court
can be permanently liberal because
they'll just always add more liberal
justices if
they're in a position of power is that
rbg's dying wish
no we know it's not her dying wish
because she said explicitly that it was
a horrible idea
there is no fixed number in the
constitution so this court has had
as few as five as many as ten
nine seems to be a good number and it's
been that way for
for a long time i have heard that there
are some people
on the democratic side who would like to
increase the number of judges i think
that was a bad idea when president
franklin delano roosevelt tried to
pack the court so i am
not at all in favor of
that solution to what i see is
a temporary
situation it's a bad idea and i am not
at all in favor of that solution how
long before democrats insist you no
rbg loved court packing we need in the
name of saint rbg
peace be upon her we we need to pack the
court it's the dying wish doctrine well
there's no such thing as a dying witch
doctrine and even if there were rbg
hated this stuff
i gotta tell you rbg sounds a lot more
reasonable the more she speaks
than than all of these democrats are
making her out to be
now republicans for their part are not
exploiting this death
they're exercising their constitutional
power we have but they're not exploiting
this debt they're actually
dealing with this like gentlemen they're
saying nice things about rbg i'm saying
nice things about rbg
and even the leader of the senate mitch
mcconnell is saying nice things about
rbg uh which we will get to in one
second
but in this tense time we all got to
feel a little bit safer right we got to
feel a little comfortable we got to feel
a little safer
how do you feel safer you use ring
that's the way
to do it ring you know i've i've loved
these guys for years
ring allows you to communicate with
people outside your door
keep an eye on your home whether you're
in the bedroom you're in the bathroom
you're down at the office you're on a
beach somewhere across the world
you can talk you can see these people
right through your phone
if a burglar comes up and steals all
your stuff and even steals your ring
device guess what it goes up to the
cloud
there's a thousand reasons why
protecting your home should matter to
you
ring has security products for every
corner of your home inside and out
these guys are the best in the business
right these guys are the top of the game
one thing i love about ring in
particular other than how it makes you
feel safe
and how ring lets you feel like you're
living in the future is how
ring is a wonderful value it's
inexpensive and so when i give ring out
to my friends as a housewarming gift
i don't have to spend too much money
it's wonderful it could be a package
delivery it could be your mother-in-law
stopping by it could be a burglar
who knows who knows which one of those
is worse but you can keep an eye
thanks to ring uh head on over i really
like these guys go to ring.com
knowles you get the video doorbell three
you get the chime pro it's the perfect
way
to start your ring experience plus two
two day free shipping
ring dot com slash knowles what is that
address say it with me ring.com go over
there right now
never more important to feel safe at
home mitch mcconnell
goes takes to the floor of the senate
and does he launch into an
invective about how ruth ginsburg is the
worst most terrible person in the world
does he launch into some political
speech and downplay her accomplishments
in her personal life
no he says nice things about her because
the lady just died
our nation is mourning the end of an
exceptional
american life justice ruth bader
ginsburg meant
so much to our country
first and foremost she was a brilliant
generational
legal mind who climbed past one
obstacle after another to submit the
very
to summit the very pinnacle of her
profession
justice ginsburg was a fixture on our
nation's highest court
for more than a quarter of a century
she was not just a lawyer
no not just a lawyer but a leader
from majority opinions to impassioned
descents
her life's work will not only continue
to shape jurisprudence
but also enlightened scholars and
students
for generations very nice he went on and
kept talking about her i doubt the left
would do this for scalia
i don't think they would i think it's
he's a terrible no good awful bad man
he's evil he's
terrible but the right is willing to be
perfectly
genial to rbg and say nice things about
her when she died and
we'll probably go back to criticizing
her legacy in a few days or a week or so
but
when somebody dies you know you just
sort of be a gentleman about it
it's too bad that the left wouldn't do
this for the right
and usually doesn't do this for the
right i think the reason for that is
that conservatives have more empathy
conservatives manifestly have more
empathy
you can see it because anecdotally and
even according to
social scientific data and studies if
you believe those sort of things
conservatives understand what liberals
believe much better than liberals
understand what conservatives believe
john jonathan height
the social scientist came out with that
a number of years ago and you see this
on social media right conservatives are
much less likely
to unfriend someone on social media over
politics
than left-wing liberals are
there's a there's an empathy gap here
they they actually don't
know on the left what we believe i'm i'm
pretty certain of this now every so
often you find a
a very intelligent leftist who knows
what a conservative believes and usually
they're the ones who are a bit
calmer and they're obviously not the
ones burning down the country but the
rest of them it's not that they disagree
with us
i don't i don't think most of the time
it's that they disagree with us it's
that they have
absolutely no clue what we're talking
about dick durbin democrat in the senate
you saw this clip yesterday
when uh we were talking about amy coney
barrett
dick durbin is a very intelligent man by
all accounts
and yet he asked amy barrett he said
i've heard that you've described your
beliefs as orthodox
and catholic what is an orthodox
catholic i've never heard of that like
he's never heard
what the word orthodoxy means it means
you believe what you say you believe
i mean you you are in line with you're
not heterodox you're not a heretic
what is that what is a catholic who
believes catholicism i know
he actually has no idea and he's not a
stupid man he just doesn't know and i
think that's what's going on here you
know
i was i was thinking about this with uh
with the death of rbg obviously but you
think about this with a lot of other
leftists i mean
there are people whose job it is to come
after conservative commentators and
conservative politicians
professionally we always joke about
media matters right we joke about
the people who their job is to sit and
watch this show
or listen to this show and then pull
clips out of context and try to get us
fired
and they do it all the time and that is
a 24 7 job and i think like do i hate
these people
do i why don't i go out and attack these
people all the time because i usually
just make sort of jokes about them and
move on
the reason is these are terribly broken
people
these are yeah i do it just to see when
someone comes out and puts it on me
first thing i'll do i'll just go google
the person and then you find that this
person is depressed and
has all these sorts of personal problems
and clearly
it's like something is not going right
over there and you think okay
well i'll throw a punch if i got to
throw a punch obviously in politics
you got to fight back sometimes you got
to go on the offensive
i don't need to be mean i don't need to
be cruel i don't need to tear down this
completely broken person who has no it
was
like not not a lot of things going for
them and i don't think the left feels
that way about conservatives
i think a lot of conservatives feel that
way about the left we say i have no
interest in just like
ruining somebody's life i don't want to
do that whereas on the left i think
they do want to do that the difference
is a religious difference
even for conservatives who don't feel
that they have any particularly
well-defined religion it's still
a religious difference it's a difference
in how you view human nature because
actually we're all broken people right
some of us more visibly so than others
but we've all got this kind of broken
human nature and it's never going to get
fixed in this world certainly not
through politics like the left left
believes that it will
so this religious difference will come
out and you're especially going to see
it come out
with amy coney barrett or or whoever
gets the nomination but it seems like
a judge barrett is the front runner
right now for the supreme court seat
you are going to see this distinction
explode
which we'll get to in one second
speaking of exploding things
you know how your credit card bills can
explode how's that for a segway i was
it wasn't my best but it wasn't my worst
either they can explode
when you put all that stuff on the
credit card then you get that huge high
interest rate
and then you're throwing money out the
window lightstream offers credit card
consolidation loans from 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
the rate is fixed so it will never go
up over the life of the loan the
application is 100
online you do not have to leave your
house you don't have to leave your couch
uh to apply you can get a loan from 5
000 to 100
000 there are no fees no i know you
think there are all these hidden fees
and there always are right no
absolutely no fees people love
livestream here's what one customer had
to say
heard about livestream on a podcast
hopefully this podcast and was able to
look on the website get their
information there is very clear the
application process was quick
and easy very important you know
obviously people have been
having some financial difficulties
during especially during this lockdown
but this sort of thing always goes on
don't throw money out the window my
listeners can save even more with an
additional interest rate discount
the only way to get this discount is go
to lightstream.com knowles
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com slash knowles subject credit
approval rate includes 0.50 auto pay
discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply and offers
are subject to change without notice
lightstream.com for more information
if there's a religious difference here
we are aiming at something higher when
we say nice things about ruth ginsburg
or when we refuse to just like totally
tear someone down or try to ruin their
life
like the left often does to
conservatives brett kavanaugh
is a good example in particular it's
because we're aiming at something higher
when we talk about our our moral aims
we're talking about something beyond
this world outside of this world
judge barrett just got in trouble
because someone found out she said that
she was
aiming at the kingdom of god and a lot
of
liberals had never heard of the kingdom
of god because they never cracked open
the good book
but that's what we're aiming at for for
the left it tends to be
that they aim at a nebulous vague
humanitarianism you know peace and love
man
come on just be good just be nice it's
all about people man
and you it it obviously doesn't explain
why right if we're all just sacks of
flesh walking around and
all of our loves and our dreams and our
hopes are just complete illusions
and we're just chemicals firing off and
then we die and take a dirt nap and turn
to worm food
then why do we have to be good what is
good good doesn't even exist
just an illusion so why would i ever
inconvenience myself to help you why is
it why is your pain
any more important than my pleasure as
the marquis de sade
a pornographer and philosopher who after
whom we get the term sadism
pointed out why does it matter why do i
care about you i don't care that you're
in pain
why not just me me me that's what
humanitarianism
inevitably boils down to and none other
than the great
philosopher mark ruffalo made a
humanitarian point when he was receiving
his emmy
on his couch virtually over the weekend
you know the left
the left loves to talk a good game on
peace and love take a listen
to this wonderful rally cry for
humanitarianism
so get out and vote make a plan and vote
for love
and compassion and kindness i love you
all
thank you so much and god bless you
vote for love and compassion and
kindness
so we're making this explicit claim that
he's uh he's a democrat obviously you
vote for democrats you are
voting for love and compassion and
kindness if you vote for republicans
you are voting for i don't know
presumably
cruelty and hatred and all sorts of
other things
love and compassion and kindness vote
for love and compassion and
kindness pleads the man whose political
party
has spent six months burning down the
country
looting private property tearing down
national symbols of unity
and now we're threatening
even more violence in the streets if the
president exercises his constitutional
right
to fill a court vacancy that might in
any way
threaten their ability to kill a million
babies a year
because that's what it's all about
that's what the whole court fight is
about that's what the court fights have
always been about
since roe versus wade was wrongly
decided
since then you've had these bitter
bitter ridiculous
court fights what's it all about it's
all about
protecting the fictional legal right
to kill one million babies
per year love and compassion
that's the party of love and compassion
i'm not saying that republicans
can't do rotten things every now and
again i'm not saying that
uh republicans are always on the money
not saying that they always have the
purest most
lillywhite of intentions and i'm not
saying that the democrats
don't ever have decent intentions
they're just they usually because they
start with bad premises
they have a bad vision of the world in
human nature they usually almost always
end up in a bad place
but just a lo the party of love and
compassion
the the fight that is defining or the
issue rather that is defining the fight
between the two parties right now is
should we preserve a fictional legal
right to kill a million babies a year
should we respect the constitution and
acknowledge that there's no
constitutional right to kill a million
babies here
on an issue of love and compassion it
seems mark ruffalo
has it flipped not that very many people
heard what he said because the emmys
ratings were way way down way way
down they went to an all-time low they
keep falling almost every year
they only had 6.1 million viewers
total that was the whole thing last
year's show
was 6.9 million viewers so that's way
down to 800 000 people
when when you're starting at 6.9 way way
down
to put that into perspective in in the
year 2000 almost 22 million people watch
the emmys i mean i remember i would
watch all those award shows when i was a
kid
now you know it was 2000 was almost 22
million
2010 it drops down to like 13 and a half
million now
another 10 years later it's down more
than half over that
and then even year over year down 800
000. this is a good
thing you'll notice it's tuesday and i'm
only talking about the emmys
in earnest now why because i did i
didn't watch it
usually they make me watch these awful
things just to to
comment on them that one it doesn't even
matter
it's not even something people are
really talking about twitter keeps
trying to make it trend as a big issue
but
very few people were watching this as as
you can see from the numbers
that's good because as long as you are
talking
about these hollywood types as long as
you're talking about the mainstream
media
you are giving them credibility even if
you're talking about how much you hate
them
you still are giving them credibility
and conservatives because we want to
we want to make sure we keep an eye on
them and track what their
lies are you know we end up talking
about them a lot and so that gives them
a little bit of credibility
but that's just around the edges the
real question is are the people who do
not
work in politics for a living are they
paying attention to this are the people
who
are not commenting on cultural events
for a living
paying attention and the answer
obviously is not
and they're not in part in part it's
technological
right because people don't watch network
tv as much anymore though that
has now shifted and you can you can
watch these things anywhere on youtube
they stream them
they stream them all over the place so
it's not hard to find them
that that that technological shift does
not explain the decline in numbers
what largely explains it is that the
awards shows are awful
they're not funny they're
extraordinarily hyper partisan and
political
and they're just not popular including
one of the most pathetic and creepy
displays i've ever seen where
jimmy kimmel was forced humiliated
into reciting the phrase black
lives matter again and again and again
now i almost lost my lunch when i was
watching that on on the emmy's broadcast
and thankfully i have a freezer well
stocked with omaha steak so that if i
did lose my lunch i could go back and
eat delicious steak
now that was a good segue that was that
was good that segway was almost as
delicious
as omaha steaks right now you can get a
gourmet grill out package
exclusive for my listeners this
incredible package includes
bacon wrapped filet mignon top sirloin
boneless chicken breast pork chops
burgers
and jumbo franks now listen you just
heard all that kind of meat i want you
to focus in
on the jumbo franks these jumbo franks
are probably my favorite hot dogs
ever i just was on a phone call with
omaha steaks
i said yeah guys no i love all the food
the food's really great and everything
those franks though those franks if you
wanted to send some extra franks in the
package sure would love it they also
have their world-renowned
extra delicious caramel apple tartlets
and more you love omaha steaks i mean
we've we've talked about them on the
show before
omahasteaks.com head there right now
enter code knowles canadawles
into the search bar for a limited time
omaha steaks we'll add
two pounds in extra burgers and gourmet
jumbo franks free with your order just
because i insisted on it
because they are the greatest hot dogs
ever going to the grocery store has
become a hassle
do not do it skip those aisles head on
over to
omaha steaks all right
blm at the emmys they they were they
were referring
to the pandemies you've heard of the the
pandemi's that was jimmy kimmel's lame
line that he said to a laugh track for
the broadcast
well i think it actually was the blmes
where an actor i actually i don't i
don't even know who this actor is i
don't know who most of the actors at the
emmys are
i'm sure they're going to call me racist
though because i don't know who this one
is uh
and oh i'm being told by the producers
it's anthony anderson never heard of him
never seen any of his stuff
i actually haven't seen anything jimmy
kimmel's done in the last recent years
since he was wearing blackface on his
old comedy central show but i guess that
that gets washed away doesn't it when
you turn liberal in hollywood
all your past sins that they would
harangue you for
get washed away so this fellow anthony
anderson gets up there
and he's standing next to the mc jimmy
kimmel
and he goes on i guess it was a scripted
comedy bit
it just didn't feel all that funny
we announced the nominees you know i
have a few things that uh i'd like to
say
you do yes i do because in rehearsal i
thought we decided that we're just
you know we have a record number of
black emmy nominees this year
which is great this is
the part where the white people start to
applaud oh
and not oh thank you jimmy
this isn't what it should have been
jimmy but but you know what
i'm still rooting for everybody black
because black stories
black performances and black lives
matter
say it with me jimmy black lives matter
louder jimmy black lives matter
louder jimmy say it so that mike pence
could hear it
black lives matter
ha ha what's the joke
joke is white people bad black people
good white people oppressive
black people oppressed
mike pence is a racist never heard that
mike pence was a racist but i guess mike
pence is a racist
and we all need to
scream our support for an a validly
marxist organization
black lives matter which by the way
black lives matter just took down their
what we believe page they had this what
we believe page that talked about how
they
support the destruction of the western
prescribed nuclear family how they
support
queer fostering affirmative networks
that destroy cisgender privilege all
this kind of
crazy leftist radical jargon and
claptrap
so it was up for a long time and
whenever people say black lives matter
just means black lives matter just means
you like black people and you're not a
terrible awful racist
like all the other white people and you
say i don't think that's what it means
i think it's a marxist organization i
think actually all the founders of
black lives matter are marxists like
patrice calors and alicia garza and opal
tometti i can name them i can
hope ultimately smiling with pictures
with venezuela's communist dictator
and then patrice calors just openly said
that she and alicia are trained marxists
i do i need to
why do i need to say my support why do i
need to scream that ha ha
what's the joke what is the joke there
is no joke
there's no joke to that at all because
they believe that if they didn't believe
that then it would be a joke but they do
believe that they
they believe on the left that white
people
are bad because of the color of their
skin
they believe that black people are good
because of the color of their skin
they believe that america is a white
supremacist country
that's why that's why we're putting this
stuff up at the emmys right because of
how white supremacist we are
that's why the only racial
discrimination we have as a matter of
law
is called affirmative action that
benefits applicants
who are black or hispanic and
disadvantages applicants who are white
or
or asian because of our white supremacy
right but they they believe that they
believe that that's real
and they don't like the country for it
and that's why they're
presently burning it all down
whether it's antifa whether it's blm or
whether it's the democratic politicians
who are encouraging them all the time
you know though there is one
former democratic politician late
democratic
politician more of a judge a leftist
icon
who is not such a big fan of blm another
another belief of hers that we can
intuit from beyond the grave we'll get
to that one second first though
if you watch this podcast on youtube you
should know that on september 28th
it will be moving from the daily wire
youtube channel to
the michael knowles show youtube channel
exclusively you can get the link in the
description below
is this because i'm leaving the daily
wire no nice try ben but i'm not leaving
the daily wire
the reason is that big tech comes after
us and so it helps if we're on our own
channel so head on over there subscribe
to the michael knowles show youtube
channel
ring the bell make sure you never miss
out on a new video also daily wire
members can now enjoy our shows
on apple tv and roku so you can watch us
on the big screen not the big screen but
like the moderately size screen
members can enjoy all of the visual
elements of this podcast
and other shows on that screen live or
on demand
find the daily wire on apple tv or roku
download it today you have to be an
insider member to watch live so head on
over to dailywire.com
knowles use code watch at checkout you
will get 15
off your membership purchase the deal
will not last long so act fast
if you want live shows on your big
screen plus the one of a kind highly
coveted wonderful indestructible
leftist years tumblr we'll be right back
with a lot more
yes there is one leftist icon who does
not seem so thrilled with blm
and the blm leaders and the
anti-americanism
that they foment who would that icon be
i think i've already given it away it
would be the notorious rbg
justice ginsburg how do you feel about
san francisco
49ers player colin kaepernick and other
nfl players
who have basically
refused to stand for the national anthem
what do i think i think it's really dumb
of them
would i arrest them for doing it no i
think it's
dumb and disrespectful
the same i would have the same answer if
you asked me about
flag burning i said i think it's a
terrible thing to do
but i wouldn't lock a person up but for
doing it
i would point out how
ridiculous it seems to me to do such a
such an act i got to tell you the more i
hear about this rbg lady the more i like
her
the more reasonable she sounds gosh i
totally agree
burning the flag is a horrible terrible
thing to do
and disrespecting the flag in the way
that colin kaepernick and blm
have done are very stupid very
disrespectful
how many left wingers presently invoking
the sainted rpg
would be willing to acknowledge all of
that probably very few
but the reason for that is that rbg is
giving
a liberal political view of flag burning
and
the kneeling at the flag and
disrespecting the anthem
that's a liberal political view namely i
don't like it but i wouldn't arrest you
for it it's not that big a deal but you
still you shouldn't do it
the difference is that blm is not merely
political but it is taken on
the tone and the form of a religious
liturgy
very clearly the kneeling the kneeling
is a religious action
the the blm supporters are genuflecting
but it's an inverse religious liturgy so
they're not genuflecting on their knee
to show respect they're genuflecting to
show disrespect for the flag
because america is a hateful place and
the cops are racist and whatever
other nonsense they want to spew so it's
a sort of inverse
religious liturgy rather than being
edifying in community obviously it's
divisive and
tears the country down rather than being
salvific it's destructive but that
is the religious liturgies why you can't
argue with them
it's why they have all these kind of
cockamamie theories about human nature
like white people bad or black people
good or
that there's this superstructure of
oppression in the world that they
call white supremacy the
the actual superstructure of oppression
in the world is satan
this fallen world the prince of darkness
principalities and powers
spiritual wickedness in high places
that's the actual spiritual
oppression that we have but because the
left is
vaguely materialistic vaguely
anti-christian or anti-religious
sometimes explicitly so
that they can't make sense of that so it
has to be physical can't be a spiritual
darkness it has to be a
a physical problem namely skin color or
sex right i mean we're focusing on the
racial aspects but could be sex men bad
women good
straight people bad uh
non-straight people good you know lgbt
lmnop
or in the blm what we believe section
when they say we're here to
disrupt the western prescribed nuclear
family
but they want to destroy the nuclear
family for that reason because
all of the structures of society are
oppressive karl marx famously called for
the ruthless criticism of
all that exists and his acolytes in the
cultural spheres
then took up that crusade and that's
what we're seeing
not merely political certainly also
religious speaking of religious people
the president donald j trump met with
judge amy
coney barrett on monday and reportedly
quote is moving toward nominating her
to replace ruth bader ginsburg this is
not exactly a surprise
that judge barrett was apparently up for
the seat last time around
and she's been considered the favorite
this time around
so you know you don't want to assume
that it's going to be her necessarily
there are some other names that are
being floated
but we are getting even more information
now that looks like it's moving in her
direction
and whoever leaked this that that trump
is moving toward nominating her
very well may have come out of the white
house we just don't know it does seem to
to affirm what we've been hearing before
and according to bloomberg news
trump has told allies that he thinks
barrett 48 is a smart hard-nosed
conservative jurist
who would also come across well during
televised confirmation hearings
trump also believes barrett won't be
wobbly on major issues for conservatives
including abortion gun rights and health
care when they come before the court so
that quote given to bloomberg news to me
sounds like a real quote
because it sounds like the sort of thing
that someone pushing amy barrett would
say and
the way that they would say it so
looks like at the moment we're moving
toward judge barrett
fine by me i don't know very much about
her jurisprudence but she seems
for what we know about her she seems
great but there's this big problem
big big problem
not just dick durbin trying to figure
out what catholicism is
but an even bigger problem ron charles
at the washington post this is one of
our elite journalists in this country
ron charles tweets out this shocking
quote
from a piece explaining who amy barrett
is
amy coney barrett the judge at the top
of trump's list to replace ruth bader
ginsburg
has said we should always remember that
a legal career is but a means to an
end and that end is building
the kingdom of god oh no the horror
the horror she believes that thing
that christians believe
she is she is a christian that's okay
that's what it is that's the big
shocking
i guess he used all these words that
were scary but i guess the tweet is
she's a christian oh no that's what
christians believe right that this world
is not an end unto itself but this world
is aimed toward the kingdom of god
our salvation to know god
and enjoy him forever that is the end of
this world
it's funny now because in this
post-modern culture people joke about
all what's the meaning of life as though
you could never know the meaning you can
know the meaning of life meaning of life
is to know god and enjoy them forever
simple there you go move on to the next
question now like algebra or calculus or
something that seems
that that is much more complicated to
figure out
than these sorts of things at least if
you are religious
specifically in this case if you're
christian and
this guy doesn't understand it i think
most of the left
does not understand this at all and it's
why they are losing their freaking
minds because this is all
that there is i don't know i mean if it
were me if i really believe this is all
that there is i'd probably just sit on
my couch
and watch like old episodes of the
waltons or something i don't
i don't think but that's that's one
thing you can do or
because you just say oh well it's all
meaningless whatever this'll be just
kind of pleasant i'll sit here have a
drink of a cigar watch
watch good tv and then and then die
someday but the alternative is
you're just so you're so anxious you're
so
shocked and horrified at the reality
that you're staring into the abyss
that you you just go crazy and that that
is what's happened with the left
you you know i always try to reason with
the left try to engage with their
arguments
but there's no argument in ah
that's not no that's that's not an
argument that's
a childish temper tantrum these
these protests you know these violent
riots that are going on
there's no arguing with that because
there's no reason in it there's no logic
in it
it's just a threat it's just an
explosion of violence and
and that they continue even to this day
there was a protest quote unquote that
took place
in the middle of the night two nights
ago outside of senator
lindsey graham's home take a listen to
this peaceful
wonderful subdued reasonable protest
[Music]
you see the cops show up thankfully and
then there are these really nice
peaceful
orderly protesters trying to break onto
his property
some doughy sort of millennial looking
fellow just gets
pushed back by the cops cameras lights
banging noise those clappers
that noise that you're hearing there
that is the left's argument
in these protests the air horn and the
and the
banging that is the argument
you know in a self-governing republic
speech is politics and politics of
speech
meaning that when you can convey meaning
through your words through these sounds
and symbols we emit from our mouths
and then someone else can hear that and
have some idea of what you're talking
about because you're referring to
something in objective reality that is
speech
and the way we govern ourselves is we
persuade our fellow citizens
of things and then ultimately if we're
persuasive enough hopefully we win
elections and then get to govern
ourselves that's at least
how it's supposed to work that is what
freedom of speech is
is to protect that is what the first
amendment is to protect
freedom of speech quote unquote is not
there
to protect
screaming and clapping and yelling and
blowing air horns outside of a senator's
home at night
that's not speech the ah
and the whoo and the these kind of
animalistic
bestial sounds that these that these
people are making outside of lindsey
graham's home that's not speech
speech has to have meaning to it it has
to have substance
animals who grunt and scream like these
democrats do
do not have speech that isn't speech
that's sound that's noise
and that's what we're getting we're
getting a whole lot of noise
and we're getting a whole lot of noise
because this is
ultimately a religious expression
for eternal questions that politics are
certainly not
fit to solve or can only touch around
the surface of
this is the protest now is the is part
of the liturgy of liberalism
anytime there's a police shooting for
instance even if it's a completely
justified police shooting
100 justified it doesn't matter that's
the signal then to go out and do this
liturgy like the church bells
in medieval europe the the kneeling down
and disrespecting the flag that's part
of
the liturgy of secular liberalism as
well
what did lindsey graham do did lindsey
graham do anything no
but they just show up and they start
screaming because that's their version
of church because i bet none of those
people go to church on sunday
and they feel like they need some
community and they feel like they need
some meaning in their life
and so instead of going and getting
salvation and being
in fellowship with the mystical body of
christ and ensuring your own salvation
what do they do they go yell and scream
in the middle of the night
like a bunch of banshees and idiots
but that's what that is you know mara
gay over at the new york times
margay over the new york times she
showed probably the most conspicuous
symbol of the secular liturgy the other
day
she was describing the masks or what i
refer to as a secular mantilla
she tweets out quote one thing i love
about new york right now how people pull
up their masks as they approach
strangers on the street
it's a sign of respect community and
common sense just call us the heartland
now of course it's not a sign of any of
that it's a sign of neurosis and
stupidity but that
i'm not even making a point about the
masks scientifically
right now i'm making a point about her
love for the masks
she doesn't say that the masks are a
great way to stop the spread of the
virus
the masks are a wonderful way to stay
healthy the masks are
99 effective because they're not but the
masks are
it's she's not speaking in scientific
terms she says it's a sign of respect
community and common sense
that's that's the kind of thing you
actually would say about wearing a
mantia at church
and you know the veil that people were
at church that's the sort of thing you
would say
in in civil society or ultimately in the
center of civil society
religious life it's about respect
it's about community it's about common
sense
the sort of sense that we all share the
logic the reason
that we all share by virtue of being
people that human solidarity
that's what it's about and that's what
they're looking for with the masks and
that's what they're looking for
with every other mania and hysteria that
blows through secular liberalism and
they're
not going to be satisfied there my
friends bad news for you
bad news if you make saints out of
lawyers
if you venerate icons of deceased
lawyers if you make
idols out of medical masks
if you make liturgies out of screaming
and yelling and tearing your hair out
and disrespecting your country
you will not be satisfied you will keep
looking for something beyond that in
your religious confusion
that you might share with dick durbin or
you might share with the washington post
you will look for something beyond that
but you might not have a country left
in which to look that's our show i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon is turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton